the democratic republic of congo has
seen a surge of violence in recent weeks
attacks by militants and inter-community
conflict has forced millions of people
to flee their homes
the u.n says that ongoing fighting is
making it extremely difficult to reach
many people
in areas now our reporter mario muller
traveled to ituri
one of the two provinces in the
northeast of the country
officially under a state of siege she
met many people
taking refuge there
hardly any other region has suffered
atrocities by militias as badly as
congo's ituri province
we are on the road with a norwegian aid
organization over a distance of just 60
kilometers we pass through about 20
checkpoints
controlled by various rebel groups as
well as the congolese army
a militia checkpoint it's mostly boys
carrying guns
their weapons are concealed but the
threat is real they ask for money but a
few words persuade them to let us pass
today
we reached the camp for internally
displaced people in draw drawdro
it's one of many in the drc about five
and a half million of the country's
estimated 105 million people are
displaced
more than anywhere else in africa
barely managed to escape her village
when a militia attacked it
she was on the run with her children
when she realized her daughter was
missing
i decided to go back to find and save
her i was convinced she was still alive
but unfortunately she was already dead i
was so sad just devastated
when i walked past them they shot at me
i had no idea if i'd survive
i gradually lost all my strength i was
having difficulty breathing
then i slipped into some bush i lost all
hope i was sure i was going to die
she survived but found her four-year-old
daughter murdered
as soon as she was released from
hospital she gathered her five other
children and fled to this camp
food water and medical care are in short
supply
but at least they are safe here she says
and that was our correspondent mario
muller reporting from itauri
you can find more of her coverage on the
website
dw.com in the meantime now i am joined
by jackie keegan she
is the head of the unhcr's sub-office in
goma and monitors the situation in north
kivu and in natori
thank you so much for joining us here on
dw news um you know as we've been
hearing in in that reporting the
democratic republic of congo has the
highest number of displaced people
in africa one recent estimate said
that more than 120 armed groups are
fighting in its four eastern provinces
what are what are driving these
conflicts
there are actually a number of conflicts
in eastern drc which have different
causes
but which are fed by a number of the
same problems so
the area suffers from a combination of
weak land and mineral resource
regulation the presence of many
thousands of light weapons and cheap
ammunition
weak police and justice sectors the
isolation caused by poor roads and
fragile communications the special envoy
from the great lakes has spoken about
the impact of regional interest in the
drc and the presence of foreign armed
actors
ultimately without a global commitment
to establishing the rule of law
to reducing impunity and to building an
economy that serves local residents
conflict will remain a problem in the
east for
many years to come it's it's challenging
as we have seen uh do you know to reach
those who who are
in need amid amid these conflicts tell
us you know how do you do it at the u.n
how do you reach these people
many displaced people most find support
from their neighbors people like
themselves who
take them in when they have to run from
violence the
unhcr and others work working more and
more closely with local authorities and
communities
in advance of flights during moments of
calm to strengthen their capacity to
respond to needs as they arise they're
the first responders and we need to help
them
the idea is to help communities to
design and implement programming that
responds best to local needs
and prepares them to to better
accommodate people so that might mean
uh building additional shelter building
building wells that people might be able
to use so that they can avoid going too
far
uh to to put themselves at risk of rape
for example just in the search of water
but when there is massive displacement
the international community does need to
help directly
and so we negotiate access with whomever
is is in control and we we plan very
carefully so that we're able to get in
and and distribute what we need to
distribute ultimately too much
falls on the shoulders of of locals
however
what needs to be done to break the cycle
of violence from from what you
have seen there locally
security remains the responsibility of
the state and
ultimately it will be important for
civilian authorities including police
and justice systems to function for the
good of everybody
in a predictable way establishing and
maintaining regulation of land
management mining management
agricultural sectors the the um the
raising of
of cattle and the sale of cattle that is
the support and the distribution of
national id cards
can have a massive impact on on daily
life on on direct protection and and
security risks
and can at the same time reduce conflict
drivers while
giving perhaps a bit of space for a
development perspective and
and maybe economic opportunities that go
beyond
the the immediate a new government is
arriving today in north kivu and natori
the president indicated that it was his
priority to address the violence and and
so declared this this state of siege in
north kiba is mandatory as you said and
it's hoped that the military will be
part of the
uh will be part of the solution and and
that indeed part of their plan will be
to
be accompanied by and to support the
establishment of strong
civilian institutions in areas where
military operations are undertaken
so that people are able to rebuild trust
in local and national services and in
in the possibility that their civilian
leaders will be able to support
their safety and stability this is going
to take a while
uh but but ultimately we we need all
different parts
of of the the congolese government
and and its supporters to to work
together jackie keegan of the unhcr and
goma in the drc thank you so much for
joining us
thank you